who would be more successful on tinder
agent 47 or doubt
agent 47 I think would not do well on
tinder but I think would do well on a
number of fetish sites that I don't this
is versus the games much show that pits
your favorite games consoles franchises
and hot burn issues against each other
this week we've got ourselves a good
old-fashioned stealth off as we put
hitman against Dishonored
specifically we'll be looking at agent
47s 2016 episodic outing and the to
design of games and all the respective
DLCs fighting for Dishonored is Lucy
James who loves arcane stealth sue so
much that she made an entire video about
the time-travel level a crack in the
slab and arguing the case for hitman is
Oscar Deus who wore hit man's iconic red
tie to film this episode but ended up
looking more like a crap Donkey Kong
each are going to argue the corner for
their game over the course of three
randomly picked topics where the overall
winner being decided by you the
wonderful viewers last week's
controversial debate around loot boxes
so Oscar score a monumental victory with
78% of the vote for his argument against
the aforementioned containers
anyway tuvo who you think argue their
case better in this episode we're going
to be throwing a clickable poll right
here on YouTube but without the way
let's get into the debate
[Music]
all right hello Lu say dudes all right
yeah well I've got a bit of a chest
infection so I kind of feel like you
know Malcolm's best friend in Malcolm in
the Middle
just like wheezes office home are you
sure that's not one of these two's way
of poisoning you and getting rid of you
slightly they also age of forty sevens
gun is actually pointing at you which
makes you think than that I mean it's
pointing it would go past me that is
terrible
we just start yeah level design I will
go first because dishonored and its
sequel just wanted to has some of the
greatest level design I've ever seen the
thing that I love most about dishonored
is you can approach it however you like
it gives you all the tools you need and
it lets you mix and match and do
whatever you want but that's not just
you know to do with your powers it kind
of does it with it when it comes to
levels as well because there's so many
different ways to approach every single
objective and you can that's what I love
about it is the freedom like it is a
sandbox it is contained but there are so
many different paths throughout each
level to make it so interesting and make
it so that I want to replay a level
because it comes up at the end with this
really clever thing it's like oh you did
this you did this you missed this you
didn't do this and it just promotes
replaying those levels and getting
involved and doing everything as like
many times as you want to in terms of
the actual levels itself they're so
memorable like in Dishonored one you had
lady boiled party so the whole thing
into Sonic 1 is like they pretty much
played out very similarly you would do
different things for the outcome but
always being safe but in Lady boils
party which is like the memorable one
there was a randomization and you
weren't sure which boiled sister it was
and then they took that approach and
applied it to pretty much every level in
Dishonored 2 one of the levels it has
time travel in it for example there's
the clockwork mansion every level had
just something about it then made it
memorable and when it comes to the time
travel one in the past there were tons
of guards and stuff and in the futures
obviously all dilapidated but you had
this like croc piece this time piece
that let you see the past as you're
trying to navigate it in the future and
not talk like you've got the clockwork
so the clockwork mansion which is like
you know pull one lever an entire floor
or move the world design the level
design everything fits cohesively so
beautifully together and that
I think a lot of what you just said
there is true for for hitman as well at
least the 2016 version yeah I think
every level in that version is such an
amazing sandbox I think dishonored and
dishonor to I really like I feel like
those levels are puzzles that you can
sort of craft to your own will to an
extent
whereas hitman they're already made for
you but they are amazing sandboxes with
which you can do whatever you want and I
think a lot more of the agency in those
comes from in the player learning each
of those levels so intricately in
because the release of hitman the 2016
version was designed around
replayability and playing them over and
over and over again that's why it was
episodic right every time you play it
again you learn something new you either
learn a guards pattern or you learn
where targets go at a certain time or
you learn that you're learning the
layout that they're designed around
learning and therefore you get a more
satisfying outcome every single time you
player whereas I feel like Dishonored
even though it's really good and very
well designed it's well designed for one
playthrough and I feel like subsequent
playthroughs aren't quite as satisfying
so your point about replayability I
would say that one thing Dishonored has
the Hitman dozen in regards to that is
the powers but that to me massively
promotes replayability as does the fact
that they reward you for you know the
different types of playthroughs you can
have high chaos locales
ghosting you don't kill anyone like that
to me provides the extra challenge I
like the powers in Dishonored whereas I
think in hitman the power comes from you
yourself and you become more like agent
47 and every time you play it the other
thing I like about hip man's level
design is that it's so well
set up for you to give yourself
challenges like you can say I'm only
gonna wear his suit but I feel like that
gives you so much more to sort of play
with and I love it but I do like to sign
up it was so weird because they both
like each other's games yeah it's a
shame we don't like each other stealth
mechanics well I think hitman has this
one
because not only is it got the standard
stealth games stuff enemy indicators and
you can see where all your enemies are
and you can learn their patrol patterns
and stuff like that the best thing about
hitman is it's kind of up to you when
that stealth breaks and when it becomes
an all-out action game or if you don't
want to break it at all it's basically
up to you because of the disguise system
you dress up as a butler and you can
walk around the mansion that you're in
freely as long as you don't go into any
like high-level rooms where as long as
you want and that allows you to scope
out your environment and have more fun
with the tools that are given to you at
the start of the game and I feel like
that sets it apart from any other game
including dishonored because I don't
feel like in Dishonored it's like oh
you're wandering around and if you're
seen by an enemy that's it stealth is
broken and you have to fight them
whereas in hitman that only happens if
you're not in a disguise and you always
know that that's going to happen because
you're given forewarning you're it tells
you that you're trespassing or whatever
so everything is kind of within your
control a little bit I think hitman self
is far superior to anything that
Dishonored has to offer you know yeah
great you can blink across a room great
I can do that in real life the thing I
love about so actually what you said
there was actually quite similar to how
you can approach stuff and dishonored in
that there are powers that mean you can
walk through areas like in death of the
outsider bili lurk has a power she can
wear someone else's face and walk around
you have powers like possession but also
it gives you a different power it gives
you the the eye power basically which is
kind of lets you see if you upgrade it
enough you can see like gods patrol
routes you can see enemies through walls
you can see their cone of vision kind of
thing again I keep coming back to this
but that's what makes this on and so fun
for me is that it gives you the tools
and just lets you do whatever the hell
you want with it in terms of stuff
itself I think one of the big things
that sets Dishonored apart for me is the
movement
like not just the blink but the way that
Corvo crouches and moves around a level
can turn into a different creature or a
different person to be able to move
about is so satisfying I like that there
isn't like a mini-map as an objective
market can have on there you want to
knowledge have powers that you can have
like bone charms and runes where you can
like I think I've read somewhere like
hundreds of thousands of combinations of
all these different bone charms that
give you different powers and to your
point about being able to choose whether
to be action or not can totally do that
in the sonnet you have a gun you have a
sword you can't go in just all guns and
swords blaze and if you want it do you
think it's still fun when you do that in
Dishonored because I always felt like
the swordplay and gunplay was a little
bit kind of clunky it's not the ideal
way to play but it's there for you if
you want it I don't want it don't want
it no no I don't want it I want to see
my way through all the way to that
kitchen food I always wonder about like
characters and stealth games like how
buff their quads and they're always
cranked walking have you tried the
gradual game of life is so difficult
it's just not graceful at all like hit -
legs must be the size of tree trunks
what's it gonna say story slash
character why did that sound like a
radio jingle sighing characters so again
talking about the changes between the
Sun and one in Tucson and to Dishonored
one you played Corvo attano
silent deadly please go vote on it
you're a silent protagonist with the
idea that you would kind of like pour
yourself into him and the story itself
like wasn't that strong but it was good
and it was a great framework for the
whole world which is essentially when it
comes to the characters I think the
world itself is one of the strongest
game worlds slash game characters ever
let me tell you why so like in the first
game you're in dunwall it's like this
old it's a Victorian London this
Victorian Edinburgh and the world of
dunwall is so interesting it's like
built on whale oil right and so whale
oil is this precious commodity but then
you come to just
- and the story changes the characters
change you can play as Emily this time
the daughter who have - having survived
and seen her mother being assassinated
has risen up in her she's now the
Empress and she's again trying to make
this world a better place and you're in
Kanaka which is you know in this like
really windy region and so it's powered
by wind power and it's the same
everything about that world is like
everything is so beautiful to look at so
intricate all of the like the side
stories that you read are so interesting
that you want to really pour yourself
into that world but the framework
holding everything together is so
interesting and the way that they've
basically worked so hard to create this
world and just like how it's this great
steampunk mix of like the old and the
new and I enjoy replaying because I
always find out something new that was a
very good argument and I agree with
pretty much everything you said there
actually because I think just on it does
to story and narrative and characters
really really well and I think this is
where it differs most from hitman we're
hit man's narrative is very very thin
the overarching narrative across the
whole game the Hitman that came out in
2016 is only a third of a story like
there's another two seasons to come so
it's sort of like the first act of a
film but that's what I like about it I
like the fact that it doesn't get in the
way there's a few cutscenes you can skip
them if you want you're given enough
context about each person that you're
trying to assassinate but I feel like
other than that the game kind of goes
you know what you go ahead you know
we're not gonna get anyway the thing
that I do like is that you can create
your own little micro story within each
level for example with a couple of
different characters there might be
family drama going on or there might be
corporate corruption and then you just
come in and as subtly as a baseball bat
over the head just chop straight through
all that that in itself is a much more
interesting story to me than oh there's
a princess and she became the
stolen off me yeah when you said you
have like enough context to give to do
the assassinations in Dishonored I
prefer the way that they like everyone
feeds into the bigger picture like in
the first game you're assassinating the
people who arranged for the Empress's
murder your your working your way up to
find out and take him on a new
stronghold I prefer those narrative
threads all coming together because it
makes the payoff so much better at the
end that's fair enough but I'll be
honest a bit like I did with dishonored
story bored of hearing you drone on
there well I'll just check out the
Hitman movie let's not talk about that
movie let's do as oscar says and drift
past the horror that is hip and
cinematic record and on to who you think
won the debate let us know by voting in
our poll in the top right corner of the
video or if you're over on Gamescom put
your thoughts in the comment section
below
your vote that decides who wins so make
yourselves heard right time for this
week's quickfire round the series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the UK team let's see how Oscar and
Lucy get on who would you rather have
run your election campaign agent 47 or
Corvo attano agent 47 for sure because
he would just assassinate all of your
rival candidates and so you'd win by
default on tinder
agent 47 or doubt agent 47 I think would
not do well on tinder but I think would
do well on a number of fetish sites that
I don't like loves yeah exactly that
kind of that kind of stuff he'd be a hit
hundreds and have one picture from the
back of his head who do you think is
better at hide-and-seek Corvo attano or
agent 47 very good point are you saying
it doesn't have the verticality no he
doesn't but he does have versatility in
his disguises and you never know he
could be dressed up as one of us right
now
exactly exactly I'm agent 47 and this is
me hiding in plain sight if you're an
assassination target what would price on
your head be I'd be a million dollars
baby so everyone I'm worth that to
everyone could you pull off the agent 47
chrome-dome look nope no I definitely
couldn't if I could go gray have a
decent but boldness
yeah hundred percent but boldness would
not suit me I would I've got too big a
head which is why I like up my hair
[Laughter]
remember to get your voice heard in our
poll or in the comment section below and
tell us who you think argued their case
better and if you enjoyed this episode
of vs. make sure to hit that subscribe
button as we'll have new episodes of the
show every Wednesday thanks for watching
see ya
[Music]
you